all right we are now live for November's
ama session that's ask me anything and
it looks like I've already got a number
of questions lined up people I think
realized the head of tanks I see some
some frequent fliers here that they
realized ahead of time that they bet
it's best to get your questions in
before everybody else starts flooding
that's with them
let me of course thank my patreon
supporters and put the post here about
that so this these sessions are
underwritten by the support from my my
patreon backers and I'm very happy to
have them all along for this this ride
so let me get to questions already
here's a good one from carl bond when
reading a edition of the Leviathan that
regularizes orthography and punctuation
is something ineffable lost or is the
full breadth of the works ideas still
retained so what is he what is he
referring to there Hobbes wrote
Leviathan in the 1600s in the 17th
century and spelling orthography was was
quite a bit different back then you
notice if you read an older version
there's words that are spelled quite a
bit different not only from like
contemporary British English but
especially from American English and
there's all sorts of words capitalized
as well you even see this in John Locke
alright and you know though the grammar
is a little bit different the style the
punctuation
so there are additions that make it a
bit easier to read by regularizing it do
I think anything is lost as far as the
ideas go no you know you're losing a
little bit of the style I guess but you
know with philosophy style can be
important depending on the philosopher
Hobbes would probably say that it
doesn't really matter that much whereas
some other authors might might say that
they really need their style preserved
you know that style is essential through
that so I don't think there's anything
wrong
that as a matter of fact I tend to
prefer you know for students more modern
language versions of these things I
sometimes joke around that because these
people wrote in English you know Hobbes
or Locke or Berkeley or even Hume that
they suffer in relation to their
contemporaries who wrote in other
languages because you can do a
contemporary translation of say
Descartes right but what are you gonna
do translate lock into English gobs
doesn't actually work that way
Bruno asks any favorite artists or
artistic mediums so I actually used to
dabble a bit you know years and years
and years ago in oil pastels that was my
favorite medium to work in but I was
never very good and I haven't done it
for years and years and years I should
probably you know now that I'm actually
teaching at Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design I should probably get back
into it because there's so much really
cool stuff happening there and some of
my colleagues and students might might
help me out a little bit you know I you
know I I do like art work quite a bit I
don't get as much time to go into
museums as I would like and we really
have a wonderful art museum here in
Milwaukee and I do have some favorite
paintings there you know I've talked
about some of them from from time to
time do I have any particularly favorite
artists I mean I don't even have
favorite philosophers so I don't I don't
really have particularly favorite
artists either but I do enjoy art so I
did I'll say that
yeah sonís XD what are your thoughts on
other philosophy YouTube channels like
philosophy tube contra points or cuck
philosophy well you know I'm not an
actually a good person to talk about
these because I don't watch them because
I don't have the time I'm you know if
you've been following my output this
semester where I'm teaching five classes
at four different institutions and also
you know meeting with all of my clients
and
trying to get a little bit of writing
done here and there and some
organizational stuff I don't have time
to watch other people's videos or even
some you know I listen occasionally to
the podcast here and there but you know
it's unfortunate because I'm really in
the position of a producer but not a
consumer most of my time that I'm
actually reading it's reading for the
stuff I'm going to teach in classes or
shoot videos on or do an event on or
that my clients need so for example I've
got Aristotle's rhetoric right here I've
actually worked merely through this
entire book with a client over the last
I think two years a guitar professor
from Berkeley College in Boston who I've
gotten to be very good friends with as
well and so you know I'm reading and
rereading the the rhetoric but I'm not
reading secondary lit-up let alone you
know sort of all the other stuff that's
that's kind of spin-offs so I'm not you
know here's the one thing I will say
I've said many times that I think that
there's more value in producing
well-informed high quality high content
stuff than glitzy or jokey you know sort
of surface level things but there
certainly is room for that and you know
when people want sort of a quick take on
things which may or may not be right or
well informed they can go to whatever
channel they want to if they like
animations there's plenty of people
doing that sort of stuff
if they want the you know sort of deeper
dives and the stuff that I do isn't
super deep dives right so I'm mostly
working for an audience that is is
encountering these texts for the first
time and trying to make them clear then
they want to go to the channels that
that do that sort of work and it's great
that we have all of this this stuff out
here all right
ap thoughts on Nick land I get asked
this every time don't have any thoughts
on Nick land because I'm in rut so
somebody wants to send me some of his
books feel free and then I'll try to
to read them pair obeys Otzi own
thoughts on John Stuart Mill's defense
of free speech so okay this is you know
we're talking about the classic work on
Liberty and I think that you know I want
to say a couple things about that
so one is that I think that Mills
thought is not entirely coherent I think
that he says some things in one place
and then it's it's a at least intention
if not contradicted by stuff that he
says in other places but you know that's
that's not a condemnation that happens
to a lot of philosophers but I think
that the you know on Liberty there's
some things where it's not really going
to jibe that well with utilitarianism
the other you know major work that we
often have students read or another one
that I think is particularly important
as remarks on representative government
and so there's that and then you know
the notion of a marketplace of ideas
where the good ideas will you know sort
of drive out the bad ones through
testing and all that I think that's very
idealistic you know the mill also makes
an argument for why we should tolerate
bad ideas wrong ideas false ideas
because there there may be some they may
be you know help us to in the process of
inquiry get to get to better ideas and
you know if we didn't have all sorts of
distortive effects that would probably
be the case but I think the you know the
early utilitarians they were big market
theorists they were really in favor of
the free market Jeremy Bentham great
example that John Stuart Mill was
because the pre market was freer back
then the notion of a free market these
days there are some but most are pretty
regulated in their notches regulated by
the government they're regulated by all
sorts of other things you know you know
different things steer them in different
directions and so you know we should be
attuned to that so I think mill you know
you can find you can probably find
better ways to approach the issue of
free speech than just relying on Liberty
Harris could you explain Thomas Aquinas
is position on beauty as a
transcendental also could you put a lien
fluence on nominalism on modernism so
the answer to actually be no for both as
far as I understand Thomas himself
doesn't view beauty as a transcendental
Jacque Martin makes an argument for
beauty being a transcendental later on
and it's it's not a bad idea
transcendentals are the things that go
you know they transcend all the
categories of being so they can be found
in all of them and in a certain way from
a theistic viewpoint classic theistic
viewpoint they they all are sort of you
could say attributes of God alright or
ways in which God is what God is does
beauty fit in there
I I think it does but there's a lot and
can I explain it not really that's not
that's not something I do much work on
now the influence of nominalism on
modernism
whenever you get these isms you got to
be you got to specify what you're
talking about modernism means like 30
different things and it means it in
different contexts so you can say that
the approach towards universals called
nominalism that you see in thinkers like
you know William of Ockham may have you
know it certainly has influence on
modern thought right and then what do
you count as modernism that that depends
on what standpoint you've got and it's
not as if anytime somebody like tries to
tell you that there's like something all
the scholars agree on with respect to
modernism they're they're lying to you
or they're ignorant or they've got some
sort of agenda in which case you know
there's probably both parts going on so
I mean there are a lot of modern authors
who are opposed to previous ways of
doing things who you know are nominalist
in some way but I don't think you can
draw like a straight line I think that's
sort of you know schematic history of
ideas
it's it's usually wrong and I see a lot
of it out there and and as a historian
of ideas I see the histories of ideas
themselves or they exist in a history
and they they pop up and they they you
know come into vogue and then go into
decline and they're replaced by by a new
one they're almost always wrong when you
actually go to the the texts and
thinkers and and look at the people who
get put into these categories so alright
mr. Darin [ __ ] I never get anything in
philosophy I do get it and score good
marks but I never really get it what
should I do do you think people with
some normal intelligence can understand
philosophy it depends on what you you
know are are thinking of as getting it
right so I think if you're able to
actually explain things like an essay
form or sure to answer form to another
person you do get it in in some way
right you're you know somebody asks you
a question about Plato you're not
explaining it by by talking about
Nietzsche's ideas instead that's part of
it and philosophical texts and thinkers
we keep working at them over the course
of our lifetime because there's there's
always more stuff to dig into there so
you know maybe you're you're setting the
bar too high for yourself and then you
know being self-critical when you don't
have to do that you should maybe set the
bar to where you currently are and then
as you reach that point you set the bar
a little bit higher and a little bit
higher sort of like weightlifting you
know if you go into the gym and you're
just starting out you don't like go to
the Machine and like okay let's let's
stick the pin in the very bottom and now
let's push that you'll tear your muscles
off your your frame and doing that sort
of thing you you start out with you know
first you go to and see what the trainer
wants you to do and the trainer will
give you like a minuscule amount of
weight okay and you're like well this
this isn't very good cuz I see the other
guy next to me and he's you know
pressing half the way and then you start
doing the exercise and you're like oh
this is a lot of weight for me and you
do it for a couple
weeks and then you're like oh I can go
up a notch you know and you keep doing
it for a while and you get to do that I
think it's very similar with with
philosophy and other things history you
know literature religious studies the
other humanities Harry asks can you talk
about the difference between theory and
philosophy does the distinction make
much much sense to you
so one of those distinctions where it's
not going to make much sense to me and
as such it would make sense in the
context of somebody's theory right so
you know a good example of this is like
critical theory the word critical theory
gets used by all sorts of people some of
whom mean you know classical Frankfurt
School critical theory and some of whom
just mean stuff that's critical in some
way oftentimes kind of word salad II
these days and you know it's not it's
the same term being used but there's an
ambiguity about what its referent is and
so theory and philosophy I mean we don't
have a consensus agreement on what
philosophy per se is as a matter of fact
the notion of what philosophy is a can
is a contested idea within the history
of philosophy there's a lot of ink
spilled on trying to determine exactly
what philosophy is theory same same sort
of problem definitely some overlap
between them I wouldn't say that all
theory is necessarily philosophy and you
know would I go so far as to say that
that all philosophy is is theory I guess
and some some sense right but if you
think of philosophy as a way of life
there's there's interconnections to how
we actually live practically and and
develop ourselves and compartments and
things like that so I don't find the
distinction super helpful I guess some
people might find it useful but it's
always going to be within some sort of
context some sort of theory you know you
define theory to find philosophy or you
say what the division between them or
the distinction is from within a theory
or a philosophical method or movement or
a perspective you can never get away
from that sort of stuff there is no pure
vantage point outside of it and I think
that's fine you know so long as we
acknowledge that dudes vibe
how come philosophy is so fond of some
formal fields would often make stuff up
when it comes to informatics even being
so ignorant in calling a computer
science I don't know I'll just have to
take you take your word for granted on
that that wasn't what philosophy was
doing when I was mathematics and
philosophy major and taking lots of
classes with Comp Sci majors but I
haven't been working in that area for a
long time so maybe philosophy is but I
wouldn't say philosophy I would say this
group of philosophers I would always try
to specify it because you know it's not
like there's a you know group of people
out there that count as philosophy as a
matter of fact one a lot of philosophers
don't accept other philosophers as being
philosophers right and some philosophy
is fond of formal fields by that we mean
things like in a logic mathematics so
yeah I don't have too much of an answer
and I have another negative answer for
chip do you have an interest in later
scholastic such as kiyah tan Suarez
Molina no not really and again I could
if I did have the time but if I had the
time there's probably like 50 other
people I'd spend my time reading instead
of those guys I did some reading around
in them when I was in graduate school
and even you know went through a coma
stays and and you know came out of that
and we could add you know why not john
of quan so as well if you want to add
you know later scholastics in there he's
really worth reading as well but most of
it is a matter of time I I've also never
found the people who were particularly
into those thinkers and studying them
fun people to talk with and
and that's that's for me a criteria in
that that I use and have no apologies
about using I I think that given how
limited our time is it does make sense
for us to be picky and choosy about who
we're going to take as our interlocutors
uh Adam titer does the self exist I
don't know who's asking that do you
exist as a self
I think the self exists but again self
is such an ambiguous term the self is
understood by who
Plato you know some sort of platonic
soul as with three parts to it primarily
as opposed to the body you know the self
as a center of consciousness the self
has you know memories strung together
the self is a bundle the way that that
Hume who said well there is no
perception of the self but still uses
the word self twenty there's all sorts
of conceptions of the self I don't I
don't I don't think it's particularly
problematic to talk about the self
unless you have some you know
super-strong conception that you want to
say everybody has and you use that as a
basis just like when people say oh you
know does free will exist
well what do you mean by free will whose
conception of it are you using right if
you mean it in this sense no maybe it
doesn't exist but if you mean it in this
more clarified sense that you find in
this particular thinker sure then maybe
it does exist you know all right oh
we've got a lot of other questions here
let's see if we can get to all of them
there's a question by three by four
architecture any thoughts on John David
Ebert and again I have to say I'm not
even sure who that is
so unfortunately no thoughts on on him
rayon ma roofie have you read Spinoza's
ethics what do you think of that yeah
I've read in tot Spinoza I mean I we had
first started reading him as an
undergrad in modern philosophy class you
know the ethics is a very interesting
work I actually have a client recently
who on it who's thinking yeah we should
read Spinoza and and I said okay well
let's let's take a look at the ethics
and after he did he's like oh I don't
think so it's it's in this you know
funny style that's difficult if it's not
impenetrable but it's difficult to get
through and you know it's got some
interesting observations and arguments
about a number of different things I I
look at Spinoza as being somebody who
you should read just so you actually
know what he's what he's saying
not because he's actually right but
because he's interesting and so you know
that's that's that's where I would say
that's all I'd have to say about that
boogie reverie are you familiar with the
work of your Jaya or Penske if so
thoughts no I'm not
Gabriel have you read Platonist as any
ads if so what do you think it pullet
honest was thought on the one seems to
be a thread there with Eckhart maybe
later Heidegger you can certainly say
that there's a thread there but it's not
a thread from latinas to Eckhart and
then till later hiding her it's just the
broader threat of Neoplatonism Platina
s-- is one of many neoplatonist s-- out
there used to be in the past we'd sort
of fit we'd you know in the history of
philosophy Platonists the the greatest
neoplatonist ever but you know as we've
studied more and more texts we see that
there's neoplatonism right it's not just
one single thread running from Platina
sin to to these things and there's many
many versions of interesting christian
neoplatonism or we just call it
christian Platonism but you know i've
written on an some as a christian
politeness of sorts
I've I read plutons any hands yeah I
mean there was required reading in
graduate school he's not somebody that I
go back to very often what I think he's
interesting I don't think that you know
we have to have this emanation theory
that that he has I don't look at matter
in the same way that that he does but
then again I'm not a you know pagan
neoplatonist him I saw
yeah and again if you're interested in
Neoplatonism there's a lot of great
research out there on it and and you
know you you can find people diagnosing
other people as as neoplatonist when
perhaps they're not
I don't think Heidegger is a
neoplatonist but you know Eckhart
certainly is a mystic patinas has you
know sort of mysticism going on so
that's you know there's probably some
connections there Matthew how do you
think psychoanalysis would still have
any impact on the modern-day pathologies
especially for Lakhani and
psychoanalysis
well lakhani and psychoanalysis you know
they are from what I can tell fairly
pragmatic you know and I think you have
to be with Lacan you have to say this
stuff actually was was was good concepts
this was just him farting around and and
going down blind alleys and what kind
himself would be perfectly fine with you
doing that he was not looking for
disciples he was he was trying to take
Freud's
legitimate insights and figure out
whether they worked you know for example
the Oedipus complex Luke Han is willing
to say in one of his seminars that the
Oedipus complex is not a universal you
know that it if it has any efficacy it's
within a particular culture you know and
I think psychoanalysis can be still
useful today in in a couple respects it
can be useful for thinking through
culture and Lacan I think has some
interesting things to say about that can
be helpful in terms of doing individual
depth psychology to figure out what's
going on it's probably most useful when
it's done not just as pure
psychoanalysis of whatever sort it's
going to be but when it incorporates and
integrates other disciplines which is
what Lacan was doing again right if you
read his stuff he's not just doing the
the psychoanalysis stuff purely by
itself he's incorporating insights from
linguistics from
other psychologists from literature from
philosophy so yeah kevin costner
thoughts on sam harris i don't think
about him much people ask me about him
all the time I don't find him
particularly impressive other than at
getting people to you know buy his books
and and book him for seminars and things
like that but I think that you know down
the line he will be sort of like a
Herbert Spencer of our own time people
will will you know people write
dissertations on him and nobody else
will be particularly interested in what
he has to say
then I'm sure a lot of people that
probably take some locks are like I'm a
big Sam Harris fan well go ahead and be
a Sam Harris fan nothing wrong with for
that unless it draws you away from more
interesting stuff Lee Lisa or Lise
do you know any philosophical texts that
discusses in between or liminal
qualities of our perception of place oh
yeah tons I mean there's that that
liminal is a buzzword and he has been
for a long time
maril Aponte's phenomenology perception
that would be a good one to go to he's
constantly talking about those sorts of
things
latinas talks about that you know there
was like a going thing in phenomenology
so it would be a good place to start
Jed I know you talked about your
interest in philosophy of math before
how far did you go and math and college
or what course did you get to I majored
in philosophy and mathematics as an
undergraduate and I was particularly
interested in foundations of mathematics
and in logic and how far did I did I get
you know I did the I did a full major in
mathematics and took my 10 courses and
then you know I didn't really follow up
with it I mean I still you know I taught
logic but logic is not particularly
demanding compared to a linear algebra
class or you know any analysis class or
anything like that all right
little dirty little secret logic
kind of simpler stuff until you start
getting into like the cool you know the
cool like you know LFA o'clock and and
modal logic and things like that but
what course did I get to I think the
last course that I was taking was
complex analysis but you could take
things out of sequence like you know you
took calc 1 2 3 and then I think after
that it took linear algebra what else
well discrete math was in there
somewhere of course they had a logic
class but that was just an extra thing
in philosophy I ended up writing by my
district 8 or not district my senior
thesis on truth referential statement
groups essentially the liars paradox in
a more complex way and I came up with a
functional notation for for representing
it and showing that all versions of it
if they were truth self referential not
other value referential could all be
reduced to two one or two different
systems and so you know it was cool
where are we those are tough one answer
from awful philosophy what's the worst
misinterpretation of a philosopher
you've ever come across you know I'll
say this there's there's like there's a
lot of different bad interpretations out
there but to to sort of patterns of bad
interpretation are the ones that are
that are typifies by somebody who's got
you know they've got one or two ideas
and they're really really big on those
and they're gonna shoe horn everybody
else into that and measure them
according to that and then there's the
skin like I was talking about schematic
philosophy of schematic history of ideas
we're like well you've got your
modernists and your post modernists and
your pre modernists and that's all there
is right and now you got your categories
and shoehorn everybody in there or
everything can be reduced to the you
know distinction between Aristotle and
Plato or rationalism and empiricism and
that's
I mean when you actually start reading
philosophers and looking at the history
of ideas you're like well now things are
a lot more complicated than that so I
would say you know really when you want
when you have people who are
oversimplifying you know and and
suggesting that you can easily identify
themes or four directions and they're
like doing that in a wholesale way those
are the bad interpretations of
philosophy out there sabha symposium and
Phaedrus is their specific order to read
them it depends on what you're trying to
achieve if you want a sort of very
structured curriculum then I guess maybe
there would be a specific order to read
them in but you know I've said this many
times when you're studying philosophy
read a text then go you know read some
more then come back to that text and
reread it and now you're gonna find out
a lot more in it you're it's not like
you the philosophy is not like a set of
Microsoft certification courses where
you gotta get through a because that's
got the foundational concepts first and
then then you can get through B and then
go through C it doesn't work that way I
mean you don't have to read these things
in some sort of specific order you can
actually read back and forth between
them and you get something out of it and
people get really concerned about like
getting it right when you're not gonna
understand 3/4 of what you're reading
the first read anyway you know and
you're never gonna like master the
symposium or the Phaedrus anyway I
actually answered an interesting
question you know I was doing these
frequently asked questions videos on
stoicism and said somebody said how can
I master stoicism and I was like you
don't master something like that you
know it's it's a it's a mistake to think
that that you're going to so I mean you
could read them in any order you like
you you can read them after reading some
other Plato stuff you know just be ready
to go back and forth and read and reread
Kevin with certain Kierkegaard a seducer
I wouldn't say so rather than what you
mean by by a seducer in the beginning I
hate to admit I've never read Dostoevsky
before which novel should I start with
crime and punishment or Brothers
Karamazov and should I look for the
latest translations as far as
translations go sure look for the latest
ones if you want or go with older ones
they're all fine you know it's not like
any of them are gonna totally mislead
you as a matter of fact you could read
one translation and then read another
translation with the same work and kind
of compare and contrast now which novel
I would not start with The Brothers
Karamazov if you know when I'm starting
somebody out with Dostoevsky I usually
start them out with notes from the
underground but there is also this this
nice set of short stories along with
notes of the underground called White
Nights and then in other short stories
maybe it's good to start with his short
stories you certainly could start with
crime and punishment it's not bad
the idiot is another one that's sort of
typically Dostoevsky and and that you've
got all these different characters
involved in different schemes and their
passions are driving them and you know
they're there at Antipodes or in
conflict with each other I am my
favorite one is not The Brothers
Karamazov it's actually the one that's
translated as the demons or the
possessed I think that's that's really
quite this will be controversial I think
that's his best novel from a
philosophical perspective and they're
all you know pretty readable Brothers
Karamazov is I mean I'm not gonna say
it's tougher it's just there's a lot
going in there so you know I would and
again the same advice with Dostoevsky as
I gave with like Plato expect to read
and reread you should with texts again I
think you you should read it all the way
through once and don't even like stop
when things don't make sense just
all the way through right and some
things in in the earlier parts might
make more sense later on and then you
know read it again afterwards and go
back to it and you're gonna get more and
more out of I'll start to make more
sense over time Shahzad my favorite
philosopher I don't have one I get asked
this a lot I you know could come up with
the top ten list maybe or top 20 list
but I don't have a favorite philosopher
any more than I have a favorite band so
I think there were points in time in the
past where I could have said yes I did a
favorite philosopher but it's too tough
to pick you know all right chip are you
familiar with William Paley is he more
than historical interest yeah I mean I
think that he's if you're doing
philosophy religion you should actually
read these parts of his works they're
kind of tedious I actually did read
through his main work and I'm blanking
on the one but it's a woman as the
argument from design in it and he makes
it over and over and over again the way
that argument from design people
typically tend to do he's worth reading
he's interesting
is he of more than historical interest I
mean you're implying that history is not
worth you know the history is only worth
knowing if you want to know the history
I think you know we live in our history
so it's worth it's worth reading things
that are of historical interest but I
don't think you need to like necessarily
study him in order to do cutting edge
philosophy of religion or other things
ap thoughts on Alfred North Whitehead a
very interesting guy somebody who I was
quite into when I was an undergraduate I
actually thought of writing on him
process and reality
it's been a long time since I've gone
back to it I certainly I know I didn't
understand more than half of what I was
reading the last time that I went
through it but it's it's a great work I
wish I had the time to go back
to it and he's got other works that are
more accessible you know process and
reality is like up there with Hegel's
phenomenology in terms of difficulty I'm
talking about accessibility there at the
extreme limit so almost any work he
would write would be more accessible
process and reality but he does isn't
some other good good works out there
like his thoughts on education or things
like that
he's worth reading Jed any
recommendations on where to start in
philosophy of math no I I would imagine
you could probably just get an anthology
that has some some good readings in it
or you know like a textbook that would
probably be the best way to go
Gabriel Connor which philosophers
aesthetics do you enjoy the most
man he's really pushing me off and into
areas where I'm not particularly
competent I don't know that I can say
that I actually know that many
philosophers aesthetics it's not it's
not an area of you know great competence
for me I mean I I'm not a conscient but
I do really love reading Kant and his
critique of of judgment was quite
interesting there's a lot of very cool
remarks on it in there but you know why
do I usually the most I don't know yeah
I'd have to pass on that one the proof
architect I have some relatives for a
businessman and they said they did not
enjoy or have a lot of difficulty with
business ethics any reason why they
think this way you'd have to ask them
about what was it in their class or
their teacher that was turning them off
on it I would imagine so we'll start
with this probably half the people out
there teaching philosophy classes at
this point in time just going by my own
experience are bad teachers and for a
variety of reasons maybe they don't prep
you know maybe they talk down to the
students maybe they don't they don't
know how to speak to people very well
maybe they don't put the work in to come
up with interesting exercises or they
put their
together ten years ago and then never
updated it you go on and on and on and
that sort of thing will turn people off
because we learn philosophy not just by
picking up textbooks and doing
assignments but by our engagement with
the teacher and so if you've got a
crappy teacher you're probably not going
to get much out of the class
understandably so and then you will
understandably judge the field by the
introduction that you had to buy that
one class and same thing you can say for
intro philosophy or ethics classes or or
critical thinking classes bad teachers
produce the impression that the
discipline itself is boring stupid you
know elitist whatever we want to say
there could be problems on the students
ends too you know
students who were not ready to take a
challenging class will not get that much
out of a challenging class students who
don't do the work students who try to
cut corners
you know I'll think about if you're
supposed to study Aristotle and read
Aristotle and just go to sparknotes
well I'd encountered Aristotle and it
doesn't do any good to complain about it
afterwards because you never actually
made contact with the the real thing the
other thing I will say too is that there
is a problem in business ethics on two
different sides right and it often
depends on who's teaching it sometimes
business ethics gets taught by business
professors and there's a there's a
certain deformation of the class that
comes with that sometimes it's taught by
philosophy professors and they have a
certain tendency as well and sometimes
it can flip so the tendency let's
associate with philosophy professors is
being too idealistic you know saying
here are the standards none of your
business people meet them you know we
have to be much more critical and they
don't they don't find ways to reach the
students and get them to see how to get
from the point a where they are the
typical way of doing an understanding
business to be which is a better more
ethical way of doing it because they
want them to be at point Z instead and
so the students were like well [ __ ] I
can't do
right I'll never measure up to these
standards the opposite extreme which I
would say happens more often when
business ethics is taught by Business
School professors is to say well you
don't need to go from point A to point Z
as a matter of fact using to go from a
to a little bit beyond a and that's good
right because you're doing your more
ethical now what we need is like no you
got to get to a point and it's and
here's the here's the ways to do it and
that just doesn't happen all that often
I will say that you know I'm really
enjoying getting to teach it again this
semester and Marquette is going to have
me redesign the course for an online
setting and I've already been asked to
teach it at another institution in the
fall so I'm going to be doing a lot of
building stuff that I can also put into
my own online classes available to the
general public in the reason IO Academy
later on down the line so alright made
of clay do you think jejak is overrated
yeah I would I would say that although I
wouldn't you know it's not the primary
term I would use I would just say with
jean-jacques I was gonna ask what am I
gonna get out of this I mean if I'm
gonna read contemporary philosophers
people who are out there doing work
right now I'll just pick one other name
out of the air should I spend the time
reading Dziedzic or should I spend the
time reading eigem Ben I know that I'm
gonna get something out of reading Hagen
Ben Georgia Lockett met him talking
about the the Italian philosopher who
you know was very engaged with the
history of philosophy but thinking about
contemporary issues I can't say the same
about jejak with what I've read and if I
have to do too much work to disentangle
what the hell he's talking about
and I'm you know somebody who knows
these reference points I'm just not
convinced that it's worth my time so you
know I I do in fact sometimes cite jejak
and post his stuff but it's usually the
more
topical essays that he's writing about
in our contemporary political situation
neon moon I was wondering if you enjoyed
any non Western philosophers especially
those who are familiar with some Western
philosophers such as all Farabi with
Plato Melisandre with Heidegger
al-ghazali with Augustine did all
Ghazali actually no Augustine that that
would be a big surprise to me yeah I
enjoy reading non Western philosophers
I'm not I'm not by any means possessed
of expertise in the field I'm
handicapped by the fact that I don't
read you know say Arabic or classical
Chinese or Japanese or or Sanskrit or
any little sort of things so I'm always
leery about you know taking a stand
because if I want to say something about
Plato well I can read the Greek you know
if I want to say something about Thomas
Aquinas I can read his Latin if I want
to talk about Descartes I can read his
Latin and his French so I'm a bit more
confident actually getting it right with
those and yeah there's there's quite a
few I used to teach fairly routinely I'd
teach world religions in which case we
got to talk about a little bit of
philosophy right a little bit of
Confucius a little bit of Taoism a
little bit of classical Buddhism some
some stuff from Vedanta you know but
well in talking about the Islamic world
we talked about some of the philosophers
as well and then I I did get to teach a
few times a class non-western philosophy
but that was back when I was teaching in
the prison which is more than ten years
ago so you know it's it's it'd be
something that would be fun to get into
but I don't know that I actually do have
the time available for doing that
all right cozy has a cryptic comment
here we've platform these false ideas on
equal footing with the truth
unacceptable I don't know what that
means but maybe free market for
capitalists to crush us all into slavery
again I don't know what that means
Mathew what do you think of mark
Fischer's capitalist realism I don't
know I don't know Mark Fisher or what
capitalist realism could mean
so let's take the next one that don't
worry does need to believe there's such
a thing as objective truth in a
scientific sense or in the genealogy of
morals when he speaks in English
psychologist he says there are another
text not and I don't see it follow up
here yeah I mean Nietzsche believes that
you can come up with objective truth in
a scientific sense but it doesn't have
the value that scientists think that it
does right so if you want to say well
that's not really the same notion of
objective truth okay he would grant you
that I mean he thinks that the
scientists the men of science the people
who you know are subject to what we
nowadays call scientism are basically
theologians who substitute in a bunch of
other terms and concepts for the
theology that they think themselves so
much better than for having rejected but
they're still doing the same thing
they're still motivated by the will to
truth for some sort of like universal
set of truths that are going to hold
constant some highest value and they
don't they're contributing to and they
don't help us with tools for combating
nihilism et I'm a student of literature
where should I start reading literature
in philosophy I say the people start
with Plato and you you could certainly
start reading literature with Plato too
but I mean that's because I like a
chronological approach I mean there's
where should I start
read read read read read a lot of stuff
you know and find other people to talk
to about it whether you know face to
face or in a class or online you know
engage with other people about it
Christopher birch please comment on the
concept of time and chance is written in
Ecclesiastes well I mean chance a lot of
things are subject to chance for the the
author of Ecclesiastes Arcola
right and time you know time is going to
show you over and over again the same
sort of stuff happening it's very
pessimistic viewpoint on things you know
and then there of course there's that
time for this a time for that I don't
really have much more to say about
Ecclesiastes them than that are jhanas Y
Nietzsche repudiates Christ even though
he shows some kind of respect throughout
Antichrist and distance him from
Christianity well nature distances
himself from a repudiates Christ because
Christ preaches a kind of universal love
says that that's you know what people
will be judged on and Nietzsche is you
know like like most of us who are are
smart you can accept some things and
reject some things from from a figure
right that's that's one of the signs of
people being underdeveloped or not
having certain faculties they got to be
all-in on something you know either
this is totally right or this is totally
wrong I mean you know you can say this
about anybody
Aristotle is right about some stuff
wrong about other stuff Nietzsche is
saying that about about this great
figure Christ who shows up I mean you
know here's what you should distinguish
when it comes to Nietzsche Nietzsche
thinks that the church as an institution
it's actually something has very clear
admiration for because it's a locus of
power that's able to do things is this
is there right in the not-too genealogy
in the birth of tragedy section 3 right
but then also in other places as well so
considered as a power structure
Nietzsche thinks that the church is
pretty cool the figure of Jesus himself
Nietzsche is actually writing in a
milieu where he's not the first person
to distinguish between sort of the the
Christ as the the person the historical
figure and then you know what
Christianity made of him David Strauss
you know as a predecessor of Nietzsche
in this respect and there's plenty of
people who did that by the time that
Nietzsche is seeing you know Paul as
transforming Christianity that's already
an old line right you know make the
distinction between the Christianity
that G
is taught and the Christianity that Paul
is is you know transforming things into
very punitive you know regulated people
had been saying that for several
generations by that point so I don't
think there's any big surprises in there
alright Adam where was Nietzsche wrong
in your opinion where was he right well
I think he was wrong in in quite a few
of the judgments that he made you know
for example about Christianity you know
a great example of this read mock
sailors or xanthoma nice short work
Schaller makes that he'll say Nietzsche
is right about the waitress on to mount
work he was wrong to associate it so
exclusively with Christianity you can
certainly find Christian authors who are
filled with Roseanne tomate like
Tertullian and you can find plenty who
who aren't so Nietzsche is usually wrong
in where he's being reductive he's very
on point about the the threat that Neel
ism poses to us here in in the late
modern presence he's prescient author as
a matter of fact there's there's a great
book that I would recommend and I don't
remember exactly who it was but I want
to say Harrington it was called the
politics at God's funeral Harrington was
a Marxist if I'm remembering the guy
right whoever it was he was a Marxist
and he said Nietzsche's got some of
these things about cultural decline
right so no that's a big surprise
because Marxist aren't supposed to like
Nietzsche you know especially not the
stuff about culture and he said no he's
actually right about this now we need to
think about what happens in a world
where Nietzsche has got some of these
these dynamics correct
all right Adam thoughts on falsification
ISM if you mean like popper I think it's
a crude approach it can be useful it's
locally useful globally it's self
contradictory because it's not subject
to falsification itself same problem is
verification ISM you know my Jim Jim if
you raise enough patreon money when you
consider founding a platonic Republic I
can't picture how much money that would
actually cost to try to
something like that no I I will say that
if I raise enough patreon money I've
committed to doing some other much more
smaller scale but still pretty big
projects but trying to create Plato's
Republic even assuming that Plato's
Republic was was the right idea that's
been tried a couple times you know Plato
tried to convince tyrants that to go
that way and plutinos himself tried to
have a Kali appleís total failure these
things but very difficult to pull off oh
jee loke oh do you think capitalism is
intrinsically immoral I think a lot of
aspects of capitalism the way it works
out are but capitalism as such no I
don't think capitalism and such is
intrinsically immoral all right let's
see here
kevin has an observation self-control
with respect to anger management
requires a relinquishment of a
narcissistic viewpoint sometimes it
depends on if you have a narcissistic
viewpoint or not there's a lot of
different you know there's not just like
one recipe for for self-control and
anger management if you do have a
narcissistic sort of point of view not
necessarily in the DSM diagnosis
narcissism but in just in the broader
sense
you'll probably get angry more often
because you you tend to view everything
personally and you'll probably have a
sense of entitlement so that's that's
correct
oh gee local do you like Noam Chomsky I
mean depends on what you mean by like
did I think he's right about stuff
occasionally I like that he's very
consistent in things that I'm a big fan
of consistency even for people who I
think are often wrong I think it when it
comes to his linguistics I don't buy you
know his view on linguistics and he's
you know he's a good voice from the left
I'll say that
David ringa have you read philosophy in
the flesh and if so what do you think of
it I can blanking on who that is by
don't think I've read it well you see in
if I have all the embodied mind stuff
[Music]
let me see here they used to be like a
big thing all the time embodiment now
George Lakoff yeah yeah I have read that
lock off in Johnson you know they were
there were two people you know Johnson
was at SIU before I was in graduate
school there so he's constantly being
recommended I don't think they're bad
I think they often leave a lot of stuff
out as far as like how communication and
semiotics and things like that go but
it's been a long time I don't I don't
have the time to spend on unlock off
things these days other than the things
that he says in op-ed pieces which which
I actually like he's easy unfortunately
he's sort of a Cassandra he he was able
to you know tell Democrats how they
should you know redo their message so
that they would stop losing elections
and they just wouldn't listen to the guy
all right here's a question from Kohn
debt Tierra was Hegel just trolling us
through his works definitely not I mean
he wasn't he didn't have the modern
reader to begin with in view at all and
I think this is something really clear
you know any philosopher who thinks that
sort of history has ended with with him
or her and their point of view is not
going to be addressing you and me here
in the 21st century and no he was
serious about what he was doing and he
you know I think he added a lot of value
to the the set of ideas that we have to
work with but I think that his point of
his overarching point of views is
actually wrong you know history didn't
end with him but no he was serious about
what he was doing alright let's see it
we've got my room above the true the
human mind cannot be absolutely
destroyed the body but some of it
remains which is eternal what it Spinoza
mean by that I mean I think the same
thing that Aristotle means and talking
about the active intellect or at least
the interpretations of Aristotle talking
about that or Plato talking about the
rational part surviving death in the
Timaeus you know there's there's
something that you know continues on the
Stoics by the way read read Senecas
letter of consolation to Martha Marcia
then you'll see something similar being
brought up but I mean the question that
you gotta ask is well what do I care
because that's not really me that part
that survives in these theories is it
does it have my memories and personality
if it doesn't then I don't know
so Deutz asked a good question which is
essentially just a terminological
question if the self does not exist how
can we take selfies you could think that
you have a soft but don't have a self
and take a selfie of the non-existent
person who the self is supposed to
reside in dk why do people hate Lacan so
much well it's a great question because
he is in fact hateable even for those of
us who like him he was you know he wrote
the stuff in a creek in deliberately
obscure ways playing around with
language he's Hannibal for the same
reason Derrida is by the way showing off
you know playing around with stuff makes
you work so hard and you know the
justification well it's important that
you work so hard to get these these
ideas I'm I'm helping you out this way
yeah sometimes that's the case and
sometimes he just you know was what we
call in French press you you know with
translated is precious but you might say
kind of full of himself
and I think that's so that's one reason
and then people also hate stuff that
they read little snippets of and don't
like what they're reading or they've
been told they should hate you know you
read you read other authors and they're
like Lacan sucks oh well now I know I
should hate like huh
you know without reading him just like
people read pop or and they're like
Plato's socks do you have to read any
Plato yeah yeah I read some excerpts oh
okay that's that's not really knowing
the author all right Western man was
Plato correct to suggest men be kept
from philosophy until the age of 25 to
be mature enough to use it why did he
think this
I mean Aristotle says something similar
about ethics the idea is that that you
know you what you need instead is sort
of like foundations and you know sort of
an ideal education you can make a case
like that but well done do you ever have
the opportunity to create some sort of
ideal education like that and and in the
places where they do people still turn
out to be screw-ups I I think the idea
of keeping people from philosophy until
a certain date is it's a bad idea that
said I don't think you need to be like
trying to introduce children to
philosophy if they're not interested in
it you probably have to orient it
differently it's six-year-olds than you
do to 12 year olds than you do to 18
year olds than he do to 25 year olds
right so all right the ever-present
asked question thoughts on avala I don't
really have any thoughts on Ebola
I guess he's quite popular these days
with people yeah encyclical if you read
any right-wing thinkers like Thomas
Carlyle Julia Cibola and Windham Lewis
I've read Carlyle I've skimmed of all
I've never read Lewis Carlyle is
interesting and yeah I mean I don't I
don't have the I should make the time
for this because people are always
asking about this and it is it is I
suppose important since you know if
people are getting into these these
traditionalist thinkers I should engage
them but it's matter of finding the time
again Philippe what do you think of that
interpretation by the left on Nietzsche
I think that a lot of people on the left
like to like to pick and choose what
they
from Mitra and they try to produce what
I call a defamed nature right a
domesticated meetcha and I think it's
usually BS it's usually bad readings of
meetcha
very selective to get what they want out
of it but you know anybody can do
whatever interpretation they want they
suppose marwan what are we in the eyes
of Hegel that's a good question
monsters we are we are stuff that
doesn't fit within his system because
his system was more or less complete and
yet we have over a hundred and fifty
years of history beyond his system that
doesn't fit within his system and our
consciousnesses have been formed by that
think about just of the impact of the
internet right and and carrying around
these phones these these supercomputers
that people are looking at all the time
so you know that's not say that Hegel
can't be useful for understanding our
present situation I think bits and
pieces of Hegel are quite useful for
that certain dynamics can be act as
foreign thoughts on the thesis of George
congoleum and Jean it belief that
there's no truth in philosophy well
that's news to me
since the philosophy is concerned with
the essence of truth the essence of
truth does not respond to the criteria
truth I don't know that that argument I
would be surprised to see hit the lead
saying that but kind of me am i it
wouldn't be that surprised but I don't
have much to to say about it because
it's not something I've thought much
about Linda what works and sources do
you recommend when starting to read
translate and the medieval Latin I dunno
classical Latin well you know read
Thomas Aquinas he deliberately made his
his writing easy to read for for
beginners as he says the impurity right
the inexperienced and you know there's
there's plenty of others I started
reading and some after that that's all I
got into ants on the first place I first
started trying to read much more
difficult works
I was like I gotta go and do some simple
stuff so I did a quietness for a while
and then I started reading and something
was a bit more rhetorically complicated
and he's fun
I'm not a medievalist per se so I don't
really have a lot of great advice to
give you on that Alexandre Santos never
really understood Duns Scotus his
argument for the existence of God any
thoughts on the argument no I'd have to
go back and take a look at it and I
haven't for years and years tony
heffling can you suggest any modern
thinkers that are similar to the Stoics
of self-help for day-to-day life modern
Stoics okay there's a whole literature
out there if people who are harnessing
the classical Stoics and and you know
transforming it into self-help i've done
you know reviews on my channel of some
of those books some of them are more
faithful some of them are less faithful
so yeah oh jee loke oh what do you think
of Jung's quote the greatest burden a
child must bear is the unlit lives of
their parents well that's the case for
some children right the the people that
their parents are trying to live
vicariously through so they have to be
on the football team or they have to you
know be in the beauty pageant because
mom or dad is trying to live out a
fantasy of a life that they they didn't
enjoy through them or they have to be
successful or they have to date a
certain kind of person or we can add all
that sort of stuff
I think that's that is a a common
dynamic that's a big problem isn't it
and and this happens too in sort of like
academic things you know the professor
who pushes his or her student to do the
research that they wish they had been
able to do and and I think sometimes you
have to stand up for yourself and say I
need to chart my own path I might come
back to your path but I need to chart my
own path oh gee follows-up what do you
think of sophist Jordan Peterson well I
hesitate to use that word sophist
because it has a on the one hand sort of
like calling somebody a fascist it can
mean anything you like to anybody
right and on the other hand I know what
the actual Sophists were like so I'm not
a huge fan of Peterson right I've said
this many many times people ask
constantly about him and about Sam
Harris and others
but that you know I don't spend the time
to watch his videos or haven't read his
latest book I read bits of maps of
meaning and didn't find it particularly
interesting or impressive and I've said
this many times before I think he's
become a prisoner of his own success
you know he's kind he's been embraced by
the right as as a darling he's you know
there's a tendency to start when people
are all saying what a great person you
are and how brilliant to start believing
that sort of thing and it's that's a
tough thing to to resist right rat reko
vet how does Thomas Aquinas his first
way different from his second to clarify
is existence the efficient cause part of
the actualization motion if so is the
second cosmological argument redundant
I'm not you know I'm probably not a good
person to ask about that because to me
they do look pretty pretty similar right
but you look at commenters who spend a
lot more time
with that on it than I do I haven't
talked philosophy religion for years now
and I haven't had the time to go go back
to it and think very much about it you
know I've never really liked the the the
five ways anyway because they always end
with and this is what we call God and
I'm like no it isn't this is this is
demonstrates something but not not the
fullness of what we call God so yeah I'm
gonna pass on that one
SP Dix what do you think about the
radioactive carbon-14 method is it valid
to ask a scientist you know III take it
for granted that it's valid i-i've never
looked into it what do you think about
the Christian arguments about the age of
the earth you mean some Christian
arguments the very small minority of
Christians who
because of a certain kind of biblical
literalism think that the earth is only
a few thousand years old because they're
not the majority of Christians they're
you know they're they're actually a very
small but vocal minority I mean I think
that you have to do so much mental
jiggering to make things fit that the
the schemes that they come up with are
incredibly baroque and not very helpful
to anybody who wants to understand the
you know larger world and to be part of
the history of the ideas so all right uh
some back and forth here about Sam
Harris and Peterson the people have some
strong opinions Brian a it's very often
thought many scientific circles science
progresses well philosophy doesn't
making the argument of philosophy
progressed why I keep reading Plato
Aristotle yeah well because you actually
want to understand something about human
nature history of our ideas and stuff
like that philosophy does progress it
doesn't progress in the way that science
does but even science doesn't progress
in the way that a lot of you know people
who talk a lot about science think that
it does you know oftentimes by you know
regress is there's a lot of politics
involved in science and every point in
time to not just back in the Middle Ages
today especially when when funding is is
you know incredibly important in
deciding what actually is going to get
studied and my replication crises and
all that so that's probably all I need
to say about that have I read David and
I'm not sure how to pronounce this
scarpino thoughts on pan psychism you
should read metaphysics of Technology by
scrimm bina well like I said if people
want me to read something send me a book
it's not hard to find my address and if
people send me stuff that I will try to
make the time although I have a stack of
stuff that I'm behind on I've never read
David's cabina or heard of him thoughts
on PN psychism it's an interesting
perspective well worth engaging in but I
I don't think that I'm a pianist even
though I've been on the pan psychist
what is it the I can remember the name
of it but there's a podcast devoted to
that yeah here I'll actually take
there's a back of the fourth thing here
wreck of that can you guys stop it with
the Peterson and Harris ma'am he's asked
this every session he's told this time
and again he doesn't really care you
know people can people are gonna keep
asking that's that's fine I'll probably
just have to keep saying the same stuff
at some point in time I should probably
make a video about it and just like post
it but then then I'll lead to more
questions and this is unavoidable you're
always 10 years from now Sam Harris
Jordan Peterson whoever else you're
picking they're gonna be forgotten and
people will be asking about the next big
thing on the horizon all right what do
you think about this person
and it'll be the same kind of stuff that
uses ideas and is kind of interesting
but won't really hold up over time you
know like I said they're there herbert
spencer's of of the present NamUs gun
what do you think about Neil Peart and
rush I like rush you know I'm not a big
prog guy but you know I like I like
Russia's songs where they're more metal
you know I listen to Rush Neil Peart is
an amazing drummer he Neil Peart is two
drums what Steve Harris is to the bass
right where if you if you listen to Rush
songs you're gonna hear all these
interesting drum lines and you're not
gonna hear the same thing done twice in
a given song Steve Harris is like that
on the bass Steve Harris the bassist of
Iron Maiden and one of the few metal
bassist in the 80s to draw the attention
of jazz bassist by the way Stanley
Clarke mentions him and Geddy Lee in his
bass guitar book that he wrote back then
[Music]
ephah are there any philosophers who
hired prostitutes anyone that known as a
visitor of sex workers serious question
oh yeah yeah I mean Aris tipis back in
ancient times took some heat for that
and his response was quite funny because
you know airstrips was a hedonist so
everything is about experiencing
pleasure and he said well why the hell
wouldn't I hire prostitutes I can get
the pleasure directly without going
through all the other stuff that you
have to do and and from that that point
of view I suppose it's quite rational
you know and and and I hear how there's
another philosopher who didn't hire a
prostitute but one was hired for him
think about Thomas Aquinas do you get if
you don't know the famous story Thomas
Aquinas he wanted he had a religious
vocation right and his parents wanted
him to be a Benedictine because back
then the Benedictines were
well-established and he wanted to be one
of those you know basically you know
what would you the equivalent they were
kind of like though the wandering
dirtbag Dominicans at least at his
parents for you you know these are the
mendicant friars they go around begging
for people and their their order is you
know not that old not like the good old
Benedict ins and if you're gonna be a
religious person go be like that
something established and he's like no
no I'm gonna be a Dominican and so they
locked him up and at one point they
brought in a prostitute to try to seduce
him and he kicks her out so there's
another prostitute story and and I'm
sure if we dug into it we'd find plenty
of philosophers here there who have
hired prostitutes but you know this is
not something I've actually done any
research into I'm sure somebody actually
has because there's everybody's always
into things like that
Brian ak how does the person who leaves
Plato's cave know that he isn't in an
even bigger cave well presumably by
having you know encountered the forms
directly and there there would be some
sort of difference between what he
observes as he's going out of the cave
and coming back into it seeing that the
pop that stick figures and stuff like
that and encountering reality directly
and you could say well you know maybe
that's also made up and I think at some
point you would have to say there's got
to be something different about the
experience and
that's about as much as you get out of
the analogy as he has aesthetics what do
you think of Carl Sagan and also
agnosticism well I think agnosticism in
many respects is perfectly respectable I
think some people do it out of laziness
and I think some people do it out of a
sort of a you know agnostics are
supposed to be open-minded but there's
ways of being close-minded lis
open-minded I think I like the agnostics
who actually are troubled by the idea
that maybe some of this religious stuff
could actually be true rather than the
ones who are super confident to their
agnosticism I've never found Carl Sagan
a particularly interesting guy I
remember watching his show and I was a
kid a lot of people really loved him but
I don't know for me if I had to spend
time with with somebody there's a lot of
people I'd much rather spend time with
gore quill nacho Vidal that's quite a
combination there any thoughts on role
of mine
I like role of my for those who don't
know role of my was was a psychiatrist
and wrote quite a few interesting books
on psychology he's coming out of the
psychoanalytic movement and also the
existential psychotherapy movement yeah
I first encountered him actually when I
was quite young because he was so
popular back then and I had to go to a
lot of therapy there as a kid but I I've
enjoyed the books that I've read by him
haven't had much time encyclical
favorite poet on that one I guess I can
say you know because it's somebody who I
work on but I like him not just for his
poetry but also for his particularly for
his letters and not just his letters to
a young poet but his other letters and
that's rainer maria rilke
really enjoy his stuff
TJ bonnet how do you feel about the
future of the humanities well I think
the
these are going to do just fine in terms
of like you know there's going to be the
books available when people are going to
be studying them and there's gonna be
all sorts of ways of getting to do it
together or learn from other people
YouTube itself is a major factor in that
I mean think about I've created 1,400
videos in my main channel alone that are
probably going to be around so long as
YouTube doesn't go away for at least a
generation maybe maybe longer and
they're about things in philosophy
there's people doing that for English
history and all sorts of other things so
you know the manatees are gonna do okay
the academic humanities maybe not so
much but that's because they don't often
make a good case for themselves you know
you do get the stem people being sort of
stick-in-the-mud kind of kind of you
know blind 'red saying stem stem stem
stem stem stem stem you know but why do
they do that because they had crappy
humanities training in the past or you
know they like to stick with what they
can do well something the humanities
people to make the case for why they
matter and they're there sure as hell
not going to make it by just doing some
very specialized cutting-edge only a few
people read it sort of theory and saying
we need to study this or doing some you
know very you know minut intersectional
thing over here
well they're also not going to do it by
being hacks and and you know saying oh
well you know Plato will fix your life
in all these different ways you gotta
actually like be able to reach an
audience and humanities people I think
aren't very good at that the academic
ones so maybe they will get good at it
good boy what are the most reliable
sources of knowledge according to you
not something I I think about too much I
don't do a lot of epistemology and it's
not something that I worry about too
much I would say I'm basically a
pluralist I think knowledge comes to us
from a variety of different sources and
they interact with each other so it's
not like you have pure experience right
you never have experience just by itself
that you're not already engaging right
through through the ways in which you
feel or think
so I don't really have a good answer for
that TD is bilingualism enough to study
or practice philosophy or should you bet
be a multilingual can monolingualism be
defended at all well bilingualism is
being able to like interact in another
language and you might be able to you
know you might be bilingual in German
but that doesn't mean you can actually
read Nietzsche or Heidegger Hegel in
German and make sense out of it right
because being being able to read you
know there's a tone or you know watch
German TV shows which is great and get
by and order you know a meal or you know
I don't maybe do your taxes in German
doesn't mean that you actually
understand the concepts in that that
language and maybe you're better off
actually reading it in English can't you
know German students actually like to
read content in English translation
because they say it makes it a little
bit easier to understand them Kant's
original German so we had to be really
careful about what we're talking about
if you're if you're studying philosophy
you can you can learn languages but it's
not the same thing as like learning it
so that you can get by with in that
cultural space unless somehow that
philosophy is really distinctively
French you know and you don't like with
Descartes right well what would you need
to have to study Descartes you would say
French but actually you need laughs
because he wrote the meditations in
Latin and they were translated not by
him but by somebody else into French so
yeah and a Chanel can you describe
heidegger's view on poetry in a few
words as possible no I cannot in a few
words other than saying that poetry is
different than other types of language
in that it opens things up more and one
of the things that not just Heidegger
but other 20th century thinkers have
pointed out is that in poetry we are
more attentive to languages own self
referentiality but
no I I can't try to sum up I figures
understanding of poetry and a few words
linden are there any points of
convergence between Nietzsche and Hegel
or as what they're doing just some
difference they both like Heraclitus all
sorts of points of convergence they've
all they've read a lot of the same
people they're both trying to make sense
out of you know the history that were
involved in they both think that there's
some sort of point to philosophy so I
think there's all sorts of points of
connection if not necessarily
convergence in the beginning was the
plur splurge isn't everyone to some
extent a philosopher I mean if we use
the word philosopher in a broad enough
way I guess sure but then we can talk
about we should probably say this isn't
everyone to some extent a crappy
philosopher or a lazy philosopher or a
philosopher who actually doesn't engage
enough with the discipline and history
of philosophy
you might say yeah for most people
that's the case but then again you don't
actually have to necessarily study
academic philosophy to live a good life
and make good decisions
Augustine talks in on Christian doctrine
about old ladies who understand the
nature of faith hope and charity far
better than learning theologians because
they actually practice them unlike the
theologians all right and we can talk
that way about ethicists you know
there's been some ethicists in the news
who are really scumbags you know
sexually harassing their students
oftentimes these are the people who are
like they've there they've won prizes
and they're viewed as important people
in the field so there's nothing that
says that you know studying philosophy
is gonna make you into a better person
but it probably will help out a little
bit happy 63 funny why don't folks talk
about Xenophon folks do talk about
Xenophon in ancient circles you know
people do talk about Xenophon but he
doesn't get quite the same press that
Plato does but he's somebody good to
check out he's he's quite fun
alright memento mori good night
professor if Nietzsche believes there's
objective truth the lacking the value
ascribed to it by scientists and why
does he say there are no facts only
interpretations because facts aren't the
only the same thing as objective truth
you know and those those you know there
is objective truth the lacking the value
ascribed to it by scientists the value
ascribed to it by scientists is that
it's purely factual remains the same for
everybody and we can rely on it for
everything that's an interpretation so
you know you could say objective I mean
the whole objective subjective thing if
you're trying to understand Nietzsche
it's not really helpful quite frankly
it's better to talk in terms of
interpretations some interpretations are
more seemingly objective and some are
more seemingly subjective right well
they're all interpretations for
Nietzsche so alright phantom upload
another one of the people I get asked
about almost every time what are your
thoughts on Alan Watts I think he served
a valuable purpose at one point in time
the people who are you know really well
versed in Asian philosophy which he
helped to popularize over here generally
say he got a lot of things wrong and was
very selective in what he was studying
when it comes to Buddhism I would say
that you know one of my my friends who
studies a lot in this really can't stand
watts cuz Watts is part of you know the
Buddhism is basically Zen and there are
many other schools of essentially
Chinese Buddhism that had a very
important role and you know that are
being practiced today Pure Land Buddhism
is just as important as then but you're
not going to hear Watts talking much
about that because he's much more
interested in the you know open-ended
stuff and so I think you know Watts was
cool for people who he's sort of like a
good gateway for some people but don't
stick with them you know I mean if
you're gonna do anything go from watts
to Hurston Smith right Huson Smith is
still you know kind of a it's all it's
all one man you know mysticism that kind
of thing but at least he's got some
rigor to his work you know on
comparative religion all right
googly-moogly I'm aware of your opinion
in Bertrand Russell's this story in a
philosophy what do you think of him and
his philosophy though I mean I think
that his his early stuff is quite
interesting though wrong as he
recognized and his book on power is
interesting though of course you know
anytime you get Russell he really does
have the blinders on and so he it's of
limited value so all right JP fanboy the
first chapter of Ecclesiastes is
fifty-seven punctuation marks broken
down into 22 commas
8 : 8 semicolons and it's lost it here a
lot of stuff here the two question marks
in 17 periods well if anything is very
vanities I think that's probably part of
it oh who cares
all right I mean unless unless we're
studying it for for its own you know
purpose I don't know why why we would
care about the punctuation that much JP
what's the best way it'll start learning
philosophy I've seen recommendations to
start with introductory books but then
what do I read start by reading
philosophy don't don't bother starting
with introductory books start reading
some philosophy stuff expect to not
understand most of what you're reading
and then keep at it
use resources that are available to you
don't don't worry too much about who
you're reading at first just start
getting into it because whatever you're
you know you're probably gonna get them
wrong to start with you know I do say
start with Plato but you don't have to
start with Plato pick up some stuff at a
used bookstore and see if it's useful
for you just went any thoughts regarding
Eric de Mer don't know who that is so no
Hussein does gödel's incompleteness
theorem have any philosophical
implications outside mathematics yeah
there's a whole book called girdle
Escher Bach right that's devoted to
showing that it has a lot of
implications for anything that involves
formal systems which includes the very
conception of artificial intelligence
something very relevant in our own
hi all right so I'm going to jump over a
lot of stuff now because we're getting
close to the end of an hour and a half
there's a lot of questions but I'm not
gonna be able to get to all of them
Richard says I worked in the the pen do
do I think Mary Jane when is marijuana
should be decriminalized or legalized
yeah I actually think that it should and
as I also think that we should do
something to help the people who were
imprisoned for years and years and years
for very minor drug offenses
largely you know because of this law and
order mentality that people had
sometimes connected with racism
sometimes not sometimes just connected
with being a you know indiscriminate
jerk but yeah I think I think marijuana
not a big deal we shouldn't
decriminalize everything I'm not for
like say decriminalizing PCP or or non
regulating oh boy opioids or
decriminalizing crystal meth there's
some other stuff that we should we
should keep it legal let's see here - a
lot of other stuff Brian no
to sailor I think Pascal's wager is kind
of circular but because you must accept
concepts like heaven or hell to discuss
them but to do so is to accept the
existence of God in advance what do you
think I think that's completely wrong I
think that you can distinguish between
accepting a concept as having a
reference is which is what you seem to
be doing and then accepting that that
you know the concept can be an idea so I
think if you can distinguish between
those you'll be able to see some things
about it and then you can well let's get
rid of somebody who's posting some other
stuff all right you know I think you can
you can make some sense out of it so all
right let's see here what else can I go
out on mmm there's a good one how do I
feel about the stoic solution to living
a good life this is from will Collins I
think that a lot of it is quite good I
don't agree with it a hundred percent
but I don't have to because I'm not a
stoic as such you know like an orthodox
stoic who everything has to be Epictetus
Marcus Aurelius or Seneca or you know
whoever else but I do draw on it pretty
heavily so I'm actually in some it's
kind of funny so I'm more of a stoic if
you go by buying into stoic doctrines
than many of the people who self
identify as a Stowe I can haven't
studied it as much but I I also am an
eclectic at I bring together stoicism
platonism aristotelianism some Christian
thought some existentialist writers some
some other things and kind of put them
together into what works even some
pragmatist writers all right let's see
here googly moogly do you ever listen to
death metal no I I find death metal
boring quite frankly
and and I found it so even when it was
first coming out in the 80s I listened
to what we call classic heavy-metal sort
of stuff from the 70s and 80s and some
of those bands going into the 90s and
2000's I do like some thrash but I don't
like the I don't like the the direction
that death metal went I like some power
metal I like some some what do we call
that the was not sludge the thing that I
came out of doom metal you know the
stuff that's more Sabbath like but I'm
not into death metal I'm not into most
of the genre metals but frankly I find
them too gimmicky and it's just it's not
my thing you know let's see here oh
here's a good one to go out on Alexander
Henry do you think that super-dense
Kierkegaard quote in sickness on to
death about the self relating to the
self is ironic so that he's talking
about the very beginning of sickness on
to death where there's this this whole
like paragraph very complex requires you
to do a lot of thinking it'd be good for
me to do some core concepts and put it
on the chalkboard sometime do I think
it's ironic no I think Kierkegaard
really does buy that so it's not ironic
in that he would be saying something
that he doesn't mean to try to lead us
to something else it is tricky and it
does involve some self reference right a
lot actually a lot of self reference so
I can see why somebody might say see it
and say that it's ironic but I don't
think it's ironic in the typical ways
that we talk about that so all right
I've answered a lot of questions I had
to leave some questions for others to I
guess answer it didn't get to everything
but that is where we're going to close
off for the day so thanks for joining me
everybody some great questions and I've
got some other events coming up later on
this month including one video premiere
at least and you know Hagel sessions and
of course the philosophy pop ups
so you'll see them go to my YouTube page
or you know reason IO or to my Facebook
page and you'll see those things being
posted or you know if you if you're on
patreon you actually find out about the
philosophy pop-ups earlier in the month
everybody else waits till the day of so
alright I'll see all of you and the
ether somewhere else